you know Einstein once said insanity is
doing the same thing over and over again
and expecting different results I used
to go into January movies thinking maybe
he's gonna be good now I don't I stopped
doing that cuz I'm not insane the woman
in black to Angel of Death so woman in
black 2 is a sequel to woman in black
you remember that Daniel Radcliffe movie
he was into scary movie you're like I
was breaking away from the Harry Potter
thing I get it that was woman in black
and it was actually pretty enjoyable
this is the sequel to that which is less
than I'm gonna start out with the good
and this good surprised me when you look
at the movie as a whole you're like one
of these things it's not like the other
one of these things does not belong and
it's you the main star in the movie she
was actually quite good she's a good
actress we've seen good actresses and
shitty movies before but a lot of the
times it translates to them you're like
yeah Natalie Portman I know you're made
of better stuff but this girl was giving
it her all and I was glad to say that
some of the kid performances too there's
one kid in particular out like you're a
creepy kid so the acting in the movie
didn't piss me off it's just everything
else in the movie pissed me off but here
it tastes me the most about woman in
black - is that the premise is pretty
promising it's like 40 years after the
first ones during World War two all
these orphans get shoveled into this
creepy house you're like all right woman
ablack she's gonna mess with all of them
and all we're just gonna go out of their
minds you know what you get jump scares
lot of them jump scares are the same
[ __ ] over and over and over again it's
like this creepy setting and all sudden
Hey how's it going what pisses me off
most about these jump scares is that the
moment looks like it's going to be a
creepy thing like the example there's
this kid he's looking at this hole in
the ceiling it's just on this hole in
the ceiling it's just there it's on it
and there's no sound you're like
something's looking back at him through
that hole in the ceiling and that's
crazy
jump-scare I was ruined chief the moment
was just him looking at the ceiling it
would have been fine would have been a
creepy moment that actually would kind
of made my hair stand up in the back of
my neck no they had to ruin it with the
jump scare birth ruin the entire scene
and that just pisses me off usually jump
scares all that the scene is based
around is a jump scare it's wasteful
enough when you have an actual good
moment that is then wasted by a jump
scare to kill the entire thing is the
worst you look at a woman in black one
there's this moment where Daniel
Radcliffe's just walking around the
house and it's just an eerie ass cinco's
lawn for like ten minutes but this scene
made the movie for me because I was like
no jump scares are happening everything
is just creeping him out everything's
creeping me out actually a pretty sweet
scene this movie has nothing to honor
that scene this movie goes its own
direction and none of the subtle creepy
moments were actually creepy to me
because they were projected from a mile
away and you have someone like my god
it's a mystery
who is this ghost and yet this is what
I'm talking about right here when you
have someone over here and this entire
area of the frame is open you're like
all right let me guess something over
there's gonna move one of those shadows
is gonna go
it's just announces it so loudly it's
like the loudest announcement since the
Marvel phase 3 announcement it's that
loud and you know it's coming and it
does so the surprises in the movie are
not surprising the jump scares are just
irritating but this movie does have a
couple of moments where you're like I
can see that there's talent somewhere in
this movie there are a couple of shots a
couple of moments that would have been
good if the movie didn't just destroy
him which just makes the movie a hundred
times more frustrating I will say woman
in black to Angel of Death you're not
gonna remember in t-minus one day yep or
you forgot raise your hand if you're
surprised at this [ __ ] yeah exactly it's
a woman in black - have you seen it what
did you think of it don't say it I don't
want you to be able to answer that quite
a [ __ ] maybe maybe you can answer it
maybe you saw it because I didn't
review up until now but if you saw it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more